mmm welcome to this video playing what
fq and pigeon young people requested
that i played the budapest gambit hmm
okay it's really one of those openings
that I'm absolutely never going to play
in tournament chess whatever happens
I've never played that it's just not a
logical opening but with this does not
mean that is unplayable at suddenly is
playable but it's not it's simply not my
type of chess giving up a pong
temporarily two together were structure
and this is the point I mean you always
get this type of structure which is
essentially worse for black and it's Eve
not very active it's just a passive
opening okay um after this rant why this
is scrap and that is a grub opening and
try to do something with it nevertheless
okay yeah this looks silly but at least
I'm it has some point what I did before
i'm not sure if it is good but i'm
trying to justify my play before that
okay well d6 yeah certainly attacking on
c5 and getting night the bishop h3 into
the mix yeah there's a page three not a
big choice
let's see what happens knight Knight g4
probably yeah it's really weird however
after I have a good position with the
bloody Budapest gambit maybe you can
play rook f3 Bishop g2 look g3 looks
really wacky now over what what what
else were what what what move if not the
CIA needs to play that not a big not a
big choice I wonder can i play if I take
here oh this special is not playing it
would be really nice if it would play
but it does not came takes on g2 look g3
hmm what about
what about Quinn age four and it's not
from be not on a gunite III drug texts
also not winning you have the shop g2
look g3 is the strange but I don't I
don't see a follow up after that night
h2 is going to take on g6
Queen h4 let's check that again rook
takes Queen have to check King h1 I
don't see a continuation that wins 93 3g
one
I don't see when probably my this is
probably my bad play that I don't see
when there is something there must be
something but I don't see it I don't see
it Queen age 40 page three so I can take
night III and then here what is this is
this materially okay I came on I need to
play with I simply must play rook takes
still check it Queen f2 King edge one
don't have a move the 93's he has
squeegee one amazingly okay i need to do
that I think it's not far not not it's
not convincing it's not convincing at
all check check yeah that's not that's
not the best the best way possible
pretty sure pretty sure about that might
take takes takes a [ __ ] on 50 time no
time
this I don't know the support is
dangerous oops come on Route 28
threatening of t2 okay my back rank my
back row rank is a problem you know this
is just just losing Group B to a rope eh
was a very big news check check
he takes a check made white resigns okay
this is one of those games made me know
if you look at it with a combat will
show you that you complete [ __ ] okay
let's let's see I mean I don't really
believe that this is any good but it
turned out to be really really good
let's first check the good ones for
white roux k 1 is winning according to
the computer yeah this is a silly bishop
if I go here once the play look ahead
let's back to win the bishop they aren't
probably he succeeds or it succeeds okay
we are ok one is winning okay but now
let's check let's check the the weird
stuff the CPC played very quickly okay
yeah we had a computer does this is cool
yeah well the computer gives widen edge
here and says that Queen h4s relatively
best smooth with exactly the line that
are played giving white white some
advantage well okay maybe the comp maybe
the comp can find something if you give
it a bit more time but I think it's
unlikely yeah this is probably not
working yeah
this is all hanging and this is not
working for various reasons amazing I
was also considering this but this is
check just one check and no it's over
let me check yeah these are the comp
wants to play exactly like that it wants
to take with the night though now this
makes up this make some sense if I know
take here please God Bishop e3 with the
pin yeah well this position is is not
not flat out lost for black but it's it
is worse he will activate the pieces and
this is just stronger then then then the
rook this is especially terrible this
Bishop yeah they are very lucky that
here the tea that he failed to to find
the right the right play here um yeah
this is this is okay 58 yeah now this
just loses he played too quickly things
I think he had had enough time to
evaluate this just this move was good
protecting d2 and and white should
should be better but it's not it's not
very easy to play or to win simply
because of the points the points he are
really weak how to imagine one of those
pawns promoting to a queen and it's hard
to win without any pot promotion here
maybe I'm okay here maybe yeah but we
had I was I really had the suspicion
that that they're here there should be
some
but the compa is not it's not giving any
good line I mean at the end after two
minutes I played the stuff that the
compounds players wrong amazing yeah
well capable I said some harsh things
about the Budapest gambit and i think
i'm right about that it's simply not a
great opening but of course what i did
he is also the player of a player really
does not know the ins and outs if you
know what you're doing you can certainly
play that but probably not and like I
did here okay thanks for watching